si sta cercando di baciarmi no such a
grandissima richiesta è il continuo
della stimolazione di vita a 100 anni ma
prima volta faremo delle femmine non ha
diritto degli episodi precedenti è
andato a finire malissimo molto ed è
anche questo milanesi 7 mila mi piace ci
sarà anche un copioso e se sarà il
disastroso a kate a sanremo questa volta
vediamo come cambiano la scelta essendo
una femmina invece più basse che sono
troppo curiosa vedetevi come ti prendi
bloccarlo eccoci qua
cominciamo dall'inizio questa volta non
dobbiamo fare niente è stato più facile
vediamo che se il tesoro
siamo in macchina no non siamo immagina
stiamo dentro la spazzatura
comincio abbandonato caso marino papa
inizia molto tragicamente la nostra vita
è arrivato qualcuno forse si adotta
adesso pero meno ma arrivato salvato due
anni se arriviamo due anni iniziata ma
richiama la portabilità speriamo che
vada un po meglio devo fare tipo una
gara devo correre star sto facendo
ragazzi gli altri bambini quali sembrano
di prima la pietro keep going quindi
continuate andare oppure moretti
ad andare ma sono l'ultimo sbaglio ha
continuato andare dai facciamo fatto
giorno siamo primi vi diamo già stato
superato
abbiamo perso ogni bacio che dovevo
giocare con la macchinetta perché così
può più parole che potrebbero prenderla
sta andando bene ha detto ecco il mio
papà adottivo e contento ora cresciamo
vediamo quanto ci fidiamo gare insieme
se sembro invoca sfidiamo a canino
ovviamente non sembra che abbia cinque
anni ma siamo noi siamo la fidanzata
vedremo la situazione di noi stessi di
prima
la prima crush dell'anno la trama
precedente c'è stato più di mezzo con
lui oppure mi disco all'altro gruppo sì
prendiamo a lui dispersiva passato sette
anni vediamo cosa ci aspetta a dobbiamo
giocare a basket
ok dove provare io a ritirare riprendere
il resto non me la prendo
ma che col issimo ottimo forse ci sono
riuscito a 0
ho imparato vai otto anni che cosa si
aspetta
a loro ho comprato qualcosa dei dolci
buoni pane
a dei vermi dentro dice proteine oppure
chiama il che sarebbe
lavorando proprio soccorso secondo me è
meglio chiamare pronto soccorso sono
riamsti vediamo
ecco la polizia ad entrare 4 propone due
scuole certo allora è stato quello del
bar la panetteria perché stava vendendo
il tonico giulia mi sento un po in colpa
nostra ma avrà fatto punto 19 anni ecco
il nostro fermo chiamo così si deve
trovarci superare assicura uno allora
noi nella vita prevalenza prendono le
farfalle oppure fai un giro in giro in
giro perché la samone facile far fare
come si vede non solo tre giorni
lasciatelo in pace
mi sa che non è la scelta giusta però è
ma perché sta andando da sola nel bosco
dai primi amici ma no che sì ho scoperto
qualcosa che cosa ci sarà quando diventa
un po misterioso ecco cosa può prendere
no meglio non toccare niente secondo me
sono delle trappole queste ha o no che
cos'è a c'è scritto che posso chiedere
la fortuna all illuminazione di arezzo
bene chiedo la fortuna i soldi erano un
po pesaro fini se chiedo la fortuna mi
cadono le monete addosso che mi
schiaccia no quindi devono chiedere
l'eliminazione relazione vediamo cosa
succede alle già morta e c'è chi già
zoom di tra mi faccio male vediamo
giganti ovviamente le vediamo vediamo di
redditi vendita di qua c'è un bivio
quindi è molto attenta questa scelta non
diciamo scuola remo
queste sono le nostre compagne di classe
complottando lo sta seguendo
e c'è una nuova compagna di se ridi di
lei o aiuta la ha forse la fanno bulli
dando ovviamente aiutiamola l'ho portata
via e ora vi stanno prendendo in giro
anche a me poverina
sono certo aggiunge ore 10 anni essere
montati in una stanza completamente
diversi ma chissà cosa sarebbe successo
vediamo siamo in cameretta che bella
permetta una normale che succede nella
visita delle ragazze allora che cosa
faccio da solo resto a casa io resterei
a casa
poverino insomma avrebbe mal di pancia
sta andando a dirlo al papa speriamo che
capisca al a bracciate viva superata
chissà come sarebbe successo se fossimo
già te a scuola o secondo me è un
disastro
13 anni giochiamo basket dal per ora le
stiamo facendo fare una bella vita al
contrario dell'altro che era dato in
galera birra troso veramente adesso sto
andando bene la partita difficile o
rendeva fa troppo facile aiutiamolo
quindi ho fatto ha quindi c'era un bivio
questi 14 anni
voglio adottare dargli da mangiare o da
di un calcio è una volta ti diamo da
mangiare gli animali vanno trattati bene
ma che sparino aver esploso direttore il
gatto gira questo il gatto della fortuna
giapponese qualcosa quindi vuol dire che
ho fatto la scelta giusta di portare una
da è un buon presentimento forte questo
che causavano racing insieme a
sopravvivere quindi 100 anni speriamo è
che il nostro crush che ci sta spiegando
che raccogliendo che hanno studiato
assieme la mano allora dice lo abbracci
gli dai un basso molto bene quindi da un
abbraccio
vediamo se ci rimane male no anche qui
abbiamo messo anni a era come nell'altra
vita
questo è un messaggio che si chiama tira
ma ho dato il nome o no no meglio di no
comunque dice chi la vuole uscire domani
no o sì certo personalizzato dove vuoi
andare al vomano dal centro commerciale
oppure al parco divertimenti che faccia
divertire superato anche questo quindi
ora abbiamo preso questo bivio andiamo
al parco divertimenti sull altra strada
che salvaguarda l'altro facciamo tutto
in forno tra l'altro anche divertimenti
che bello
che bello guarda dietro però c'è quello
lì che ti fa andare in altre no
mi sa che abbiamo girato purtroppo si è
venuta la nausea
dobbiamo togliere dai forse stanno un po
male
sentendo male secondo me è meglio
fermarsi o no la ruota panoramica e
bello 17 a sto finendo la sua suola per
dinamica high school e cioè la nostra
scuola superiore finisce prima perché
quello di nuovo il 17 adesso qua c'è un
bivio importante
poi c'è anche la stellina lì dalla
prossima vediamo che scelta prendiamo
per noi e sono con i miei amici di notte
cosa succederà adesso dicono di entrare
in questa struttura abbandonata
non so se una buona poi succederà
qualcosa è una piscina di notte è un po
sporco e vostra piscina è
particolarmente sì forse abbandonata ma
passerà il mio crash no
un altro maestro e che sta facendo le
ombre cinesi
si sta dichiarando e ora che cosa faccio
assolvo lui sta cercando di baciarmi
allora scelgo lui all altra prova
rifiuto era già fidanzata con l'altro
quindi il rifiuto guarda un pronto a
stettino vediamo quanti ci mettiamo
grandi non mi dire che sta invecchiando
guarda come appena 18 anni perché belle
che stiamo uniti capelli lunghi o noti
nuovo religioso
poverino devo aiutarlo dice aiutano pure
vengono persone aiuto benino aiutiamolo
speriamo che non arrivi la mamma no è
scappata scavando ma io l'ho salvato che
cosa ha fatto mi ha lasciato un corso di
miele ci saranno le armi per fortuna
all'orto mi ha mandato pazzo e un bivio
quindi stiamo segna però la scelta vi
sto parlando allo specchio
devo scegliere che rivestiva emettere un
quesito normali un vestito sexy come
abbiamo invertito normale fratello che
stiamo andando
questo non lo so ma ho capito che stiamo
forse siamo al college e piero diventare
invece un'altra scelta si potrebbe
portare indietro il vero forse qualcosa
al computer resta la mia compagna di
college con un cuoricino forse sei
innamorata di dicono cosa braccio
ecco scusa scusa allontana di corsa
continuare a fare come capire io me ne
ho preso un'altra strada quindi 21 anni
vediamo che cosa succede adesso no
diventiamo montagna come prima ma perché
a 21 anni siamo qua allora una parte c'è
il pericolo è altra parola vista
panoramica ora sappiamo che questo gioco
a trabocchetto
quindi possiamo andare nel pericolo
privata dove poi non è un pellicola
vediamo cosa c'è un arcobaleno
dov'è il pericolo 22
siamo nella sala giochi non siamo al
cinema che cosa serve un film horror o
un film comico per vivere le cose paura
volta e quindi se vorrò rivediamo si
chiama banking man quindi loro zucca
mettiamo tanta gente è uscito uno
schermo e soprattutto non ce l'avessimo
al cinema affermato da soli con un
calcio per ora adoro la vita di perdere
molto bello aveva primo sì l'altra era
tragica vera
vedo che invece sta andando benissimo
siamo in piscina a mano e chi siamo dove
siamo
penso si contrastano in costume sono
cresciuto un sacco siamo entrate ma c'è
il bagnino perché sono in acqua sulle
scarpe qualità degli stivali continuo a
nuotare o fai finta di affogare no non
ti fa perché può essere pericoloso e di
continuo danut annotare anche se c'è il
bagnino a modo completo dobbiamo per
forza fare finta di affogare salva forse
questo sarà il nostro futuro mari 3
spingeremo bocca è stato fatto tutto a
posto per questo però va 24 anni la
spezia
tornando a casa forse lo stiamo ancora
questa è la nostra compagno di college e
poi c'è il bagnino ma cosa ci fanno loro
assieme ma poi il bagnino sto sempre
costume da bagno dentro al college è un
po strano che studia un mangia della
torta maggio della torta premi sul primo
bacio della roma
tale se li mangiano sopra a quella torta
che stavano mangiando sembrava tipo un
pezzo di libro succede forse la torta
era avvelenato perché sono tutti a terra
o forse hanno ballato troppo no penso
che mi sento male
guarda che muovendo le allucinazioni era
meglio non mangiarla quella torta era
una trappola un cane atto di citazione
pure io no no siamo già morti
ove non ci credo che stiamo morti a 24
anni investiti perché abbiamo mangiato
la torta da uno sconosciuto che era bene
realtà si potrebbe ad accarezzare il
gatto e sospirato allora saluterà
miliare per studiare la soluzione quindi
siamo arrivati a 25 comunque sta andando
molto meglio si lavora già finito il
college
su cui eseguire laurea ti ricordi tutto
quello che ha imparato qui devo dire o
dammi il foglio della laurea oppure
laurea oppure si mette la radice
quadrata di meno 9
a meno 3 o 3 piano terra mentre vediamo
è sbagliato
ok ripresa che sta che ancora non è
successo niente di tragico ma trovo
strano ci siamo svegliati
vorrei essere un lavoro penso dovevo
fare l'esame di guida
forse troppo tardi perché erano le 11
tipo come mi vesto normale o anormale
personalizzate presente cioè keanu
reeves colui che stavamo facendo l'esame
di guida con una macchina sportiva
wow se devo fare c'è un'ora bene se un
dosso dossi stop stop ti fermi allo stop
contino andar bene timargarah poco
felice di continuare a nargi avrebbe
schiacciato il bus continua ad aspettare
o sorpassate aspettare finora tutto bene
non è più una macchina ti avrò ei solo
perché temo andando piano accelera su
una costa volta costa
per noi la costa vediamo beh è meglio
che si sorpassi ma va
si no ma ho anche se io ho molta paura
del fuoco ma vabbè riusciremo a fare il
pompiere lo stesso che succede c'è un
gatto perché ci hanno chiamato i
pompieri servono anche ieri maria d'oro
allora disse o tiro in un salvagente o
scrive il salvagente oppure mi butto e
secondo me il gatto non riesce in
maniera semi butto via possono causare
tutto ok
che bravo pericolo sono salvato il gatto
ma bellissimo questo nuovo grazie a 29
io non ci posso credere che abbiamo
fatto che viene fatto piacere pericoloso
aveva stesso ragazzo di prima il
proprietario del gatto o no c'è una
personalità ma o è troppo tardi per
salvarla o no sono sicuro che sta per si
no
crollato tutto sono ormai noto la porta
di nuovo a 29 anni e proviamo dai quindi
devo una storia l'ha dentro me terribile
forse magari possiamo ritornare per
prenderla vediamo o meno il nostro
collega può andare a prenderla esploso
tutto poverino abbiamo comunque ha
separato il livello però è stato world
router e io ovviamente dormo benissimo
sfruttate o no cosa ho dimenticato e
keira fa colazione
ti ho preparato una colazione con
l'aiuto del ritardo mangia un riffing
maggio è meglio manga meglio ribasso
le persone mi dispiace però io le chiamo
mio capo è arrabbiato perché siamo
arrivati in ritardo di ci sto chiamando
qualcuno bichir a tuo padre è andato in
ospedale
forse era meglio che non mangiavamo no
era meglio se mangiamo tuba trapuntata
con voi l'avete fatto il possibile mi
dispiace fermo non ho detto che
bisognava mangiare non ci credo
la salita era bocciare e quando sei in
dubbio meglio mangiare cosa che faccio
mangerei mangiavo e speriamo di salvarci
le 21 salutando mista che si arrabbierà
molti anni fa colazione dalle un dalle
12 alle 22 vediamo la spiccata i cui
compagni si sono fatti male perché non
c'eri non ti meriti questo lavoro sta e
licenziato abbiamo perso il lavoro
però abbiamo salvato lo sformato almeno
per ora più da fare
ci sono un sacco di billy adesso quale
sarà la scelta abbiamo per morire un
terremoto come ultima cosa devo fare
nell'armadio nasconditi sotto il tavolo
oppure sotto oppure dentro il guardaroba
sotto tavolo un banco sul tavolo
scegliete voi ora la prossima e quindi
iscrivetevi commenti mi devono stato
arrestato al tavolo roba
scrivetelo nei commenti in estate un mi
piace
il continuo il comando a finire lo
scopriremo assieme ora picasso 4
reselling a predicare prevede i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite
buona visione